gaymard et au bonjour et merci d'être en
direct avec nous alors on imagine que
les annonces de 10 et veyran n'arrange
pas les choses dans quel état d'esprit
êtes-vous aujourd'hui
donc le mot confinement nous ça fait un
petit moment qu'on l'attend on nous
disait encore il ya une semaine que
c'était un mot quasiment interdit les
voilà aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il a prononcé et on se fait
pas tellement d'illusions sur sur le
fait qu'il va être définitivement
annoncé la semaine prochaine ou la
semaine suivante
voilà pour nous c'est une situation qui
est de plus en plus dramatique faut se
dire que déjà les entrepreneurs que nous
sommes ça fait quasiment 10 mois que on
vit sur nos économies
aujourd'hui j'ai une précarisation de
notre profession on n'a toujours aucune
visibilité
ce qu'on réclame depuis des mois des
mois des mois est de plus en plus des
situations assez ubuesque par rapport au
fonds de solidarité des décalages
importants dans le remboursement du
chômage partiel et des trésoreries
complètement exemple de nos entreprises
et nous la verde werber des drames
justement est ce que vous attendez
davantage dead qui peuvent être mises en
place où elles sont sont aujourd'hui
rend finalement ces aides
on est dans des situations ubuesques
ainsi en une minute je vais vous en
donner une
il ya le report des charges sociales
donc on descend que vous appelez lurçat
vous avez une petite dette sociale ou
vous dit non pour l'instant tant que
vous n'êtes pas sorti de la crise
sociale donc on n'est pas sorti de la
crise sanitaire
mais rien en place ne vous inquiétez pas
donc vous utilisez votre une solidarité
aussi pour régler d'autres d'autres
choses
vous faites votre demande de fonds de
solidarité au mois de janvier et lors on
vous le refuse parce que vous avez une
dette sociale et vous êtes parti là dans
le mille feuille administratif ce qui
pouvait avancer délais qui sont hyper
importants ça plonge les les patrons
dans une angoisse colle on a l'air des
cas de plus en plus le versement de nos
salaires nos employés et font des
efforts hyper important on n'a plus de
trésorerie
c'est terrible ouais c'est terrible
alors on parle des deux mais en vérité
ce ne sont pas des êtres et des
indemnités parce qu'aujourd'hui on nous
empêche de gagner notre vie alors pour
des raisons sanitaires
on a l'impression que toutes les
solutions ne sont pas envisagées madame
launay envisage elle disait que
peut-être un confinement partielle de la
population à risque pourraient permettre
de libérer un peu l'activité
on sait pas si ce sont des bonnes
solutions mais on a surtout l'impression
ne sont pas des solutions qui sont
envisagées et nous on aimerait que
toutes les solutions puissent être
envisagés pour vraiment que nos
entreprises puissent survivre
ces derniers jours beaucoup de rumeurs
ont circulé sur les dates de réouverture
certaines annonces et même en avril en
tout cas pas avant le mois de mars
ces informations étaient a démentie par
le gouvernement mais comment est-ce que
vous voilà vous percevez justement cette
cette maladresse s'en va dire dans la
communication des maladresses dans la
communication elles sont là elles sont
là depuis depuis depuis longtemps quand
on voit la sortie de d'olivier du soap
un sûr c'est la fin de quoi qu'il en
coûte alors déjà dû quoi qu'il en coûte
vous vous dire qu'on ait beaucoup de
patrons d'entreprise a rajouté de notre
poche aucune solidarité pour couvrir les
frais fixes
un de nos de nos entreprises donc le
quoi qu'il en coûte
ça a été un vrai quoi qu'il en coûte et
tout d'un coup on a l'impression qu'on
nous rend service en faisant en sources
à nous on nous empêche juste de
travailler alors pour des raisons de
santé pour des raisons sanitaires on
peut l'entendre etc
mais on va en même temps on a des
charges on a des coups qui sont fixes
qui sont pas prises en charge
donc et on n'a pas de plan de visibilité
et on en a jamais eu depuis le départ
aujourd'hui nous on n'espère pas dans la
profession quand on en parle entre nous
personne ne croit à une réouverture
encore avec des contraintes d'ailleurs
avant le mois d'avril donc alors
beaucoup de restaurants de cafés ont dû
mettre la clé sous la porte depuis le
début de cette crise on avait également
des actions de la part des restaurateurs
à paris ou encore à marseille est-ce que
voilà vous pensez que la colère va de
nouveau à gagner la rue dans les
prochains jours je ne sais pas si elle
va gagner la rue mais ce que je peux
vous dire en pot mois faisant partie de
plusieurs groupes de restaurateurs c'est
la colère et d'un train de monter est en
train de monter pas uniquement par
rapport par rapport aux annonces d'aller
en train d'augmenter par rapport aux
situations personnelles
un des restaurateurs encore une fois il
ya une vraie précarisation aujourd'hui
on ne se verse plus de revenus depuis
des mois et des mois et des mois on a
les charges de l'entreprise on a les
charges personnelles on a nos employés
qui font des efforts pour soutenir pour
soutenir l'entreprise
et on a la pression et on voit aussi
autour de nous la vie qui continue dans
les centres commerciaux
vous n'avez pas le droit de rentrer dans
un restaurant pour prendre vos plats à
emporter un par contre vous pouvez
rentrer dans une boulangerie
enfin on a vraiment l'impression que il
ya le reste deux il ya des entreprises
en général et puis il ya la restauration
qui a un régime particulier très strict
très suivi très encadré et ça commence à
devenir très dur et les gens ils sont
dans une angoisse de survie quand on est
dans une angoisse de survie la colère
vous gagne inévitablement
merci beaucoup en tout cas olivier
bertaux d'avoir répondu à nos questions
ce matin je rappelle que vous êtes
gérant d'un bistrot à paris